hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e catégorie way fait trop
[Rires]
c'est pour éviter l'éclosion des
bagnoles
série va expliquer aux téléspectateurs
est ce que ça arrive quelque chose
ecoutons-la essayer c'est pas trop mal
toi ta gueule aussi face à dia ne fut
pas mal
j'aime bien
et met ses effets mais sur rigoler c'est
alors attention est ce qu'on peut lui
montrer ce qui va vraiment faire oui oui
oui mais est-ce qu'on peut
m
[Applaudissements]
il
ce soir exceptionnellement bas via
quelque chose qu'on a pas l'habitude de
faire mais moi c'est venez ici vous
allez jouer hausse et plus c'est moi oui
j'adore
vous avez ainsi plus chez moi vous allez
gagner vous allez jouer pour indemniser
les cheveux passage pour la cravate vous
allez partir dans la prochaine fournée
pour las vegas avec toute l'équipe de
cyril hanouna sert aussi ça je peux te
parler de minutes en afrique